ataques por la noche
Y de nuevo por el día kiev sufrió dos
bombardeos múltiples el lunes
en total durante el último día el
enemigo lanzó 97 ataques aéreos la
probabilidad de lanzar misiles y ataques
aéreos en todo el territorio de Ucrania
sigue siendo alta desde Rusia
reivindicaron haber provocado daños en
bases aéreas ucranianas en el décimo
sexto día de ataques aéreos del mes de
mayo
el objetivo del ataque fue alcanzado
todos los objetivos asignados fueron
destruidos como resultado del ataque
fueron alcanzados cuarteles generales de
batalla y estaciones de radar así como
equipos de Aviación y depósitos de
municiones y armas
pero más allá de los daños el miedo de
ciudadanos en kiev imágenes de pánico
entre los locales carreras por las
calles buscando Refugio el metro usado
como escondite y restos de un misil Ruso
en una concurrida calle
estamos muy cansados estamos de estos
ataques No puedes dormir tranquilo por
la noche porque algo está volando
constantemente algo está golpeando en
algún lugar de la calle
el campo de batalla diplomático también
se complica en una visita a nairobi y
Kenia el canciller sergey labrov amenazó
con no renovar el acuerdo de granos del
mar Negro recientemente prolongado hasta
el 17 de julio
si todo permanece como está y
Aparentemente lo hará Entonces será
necesario partir del hecho de que ya no
funciona
un acuerdo auspiciado por la ONU y por
Turquía donde precisamente el kremlin ha
mostrado su satisfacción por la
reelección de su socio la acepta allí
perdón